okay okay okay okay hey what's up there
are no lower thirds but that's fine that
okay just Friday and we're playing more
Mortal Kombat video games so we're
moving right along we've played 1 2 & 3
ultimate and today we're starting up for
yep and then we're gonna move into
spin-offs it's the the the wonderful
wonderful spin-offs Special Forces
mythology sub-zero and Shaolin monks
which should be all a good time yeah so
buckle up and prepare to go on a
wonderful adventure with all both of us
all at once yeah and we'll have a good
time
ok get that get that good over there set
switch it over oh oh cool setups these
cool things there we go
Mortal Kombat Maghreb 1 combat 4 this is
the PlayStation version yes because
there's no really good way to play the
arcade version without emulation yeah
like so this controller is I haven't I
don't think I've ever actually played
with the original PlayStation game yeah
but no I've always controller that's ok
yeah it's it's fine I'm good
I immediately fell into putting my
thumb's right we fell past it I'm gonna
be careful here cuz I have like all the
setup around me all these why you've got
a whole bunch of wires next year
original PlayStation oh boy what is this
I didn't know it had a live-action intro
scene what the slashing edge of the
blade
world combat that was excellent I was
clearly like a TV ad oh it definitely is
repurposed checking number of free
blocks ding so I I only played this game
at a friend's house
and I remember getting really jazzed
when we figure out how to pull out the
weapons because that was like a big
thing for this one yeah okay so I guess
just go right into I think arcade then I
interrupt you uh if you could X it'll
yeah there we go
player one join in there we go all right
oh look at that oh my god I gotta go
roof you gotta go my boy a cage I'm
gonna go for that's okay it's okay look
it's it's been a week
so trying to remember I don't know how
how the moves have changed coming into
this game there is no move list actually
no yeah yeah if you pause but it's just
continue restarting quit it so trying to
like this is weird this is like the
first three oh heck yeah
alright alright you got shadow kick
still you got both of her or lobs you
got a mama fours my game I'm calling it
right now
Wow skin speedy yeah right it feels
pretty good
oh we got a sidestep button yeah you can
sidestep in this one it's weird I don't
like that okay there's our crotch punch
we're good I like hey I've got to be
able to combo it in
any of the combo there we go
I feel like they changed his move list
alright every every character has a
weapon how do you pull it out that's a
good question if anyone can remember how
to do it game I think this is my first
time playing oh so this is all new to me
I've never played for dang it's it's
also kind of weird even though we've
been doing this to remember to push oh
yeah you know you know how I deal with
that I never block just don't walk ever
block there we go get that throw
I heard he missed the real actors yeah
the end of an era so on I the input for
your bicycle pick is either gonna still
be holding circle for 4 seconds or 24 or
backward forward circle there perfect
oh jeez the camera angle in case you
didn't know we're we're in the the 3d
era it's here it's happened
fireball and it's not down forward yeah
also like how Johnny cages Oh like I'm
falling nice uh that's real good that's
really good
I like how Johnny cages uppercut happens
tonight wait does he like spike oh he's
definitely gonna hit spikes come on he's
with spikes see it gives you the
fatality if you couldn't do if I tell I
like that I love it a lot of these
characters I don't recognize like who is
this guy uh it's a good question also
random and hidden oh oh so you don't
have to have oh no I messed up it's okay
I'll fix effect Sonya and then nailed it
are you guys gonna do co-op the story
mode for Shaolin monks yes we are that
we are we are what was that
Sonia is here and she's got some things
to say this is sweeps are still good one
like divert your attention to the face
and the background it's a heck of a
thing I mean there lacks except for the
face guy and I think there's a lack of
charm guys very good the real one is the
forest when we get there there we go
dude I know like none of his moves
definitely need to move up a pulp a move
list
oh definitely cuz he'll do laughter
voyage
just do some sweet combos Oh tile combos
alright basically this will probably
work steppings
it's not a very strong side it's not a
very strong side step it barely seems to
work I think I think everyone has that
same combo they know that the uppercuts
the thing oh man I don't know what evens
nailed it all right hey look some pulled
that move list
we'll watch sony blade to fall to her
death
see here
special moves in MK secrets comm also a
good animal combat take if you're doing
a combat cast yeah it's true I know
they're going over a noob saibot we
exciting and looking at taking a peek at
their uh their twitch setup
I also says they might be doing a
breakdown of Aaron black possibly so
that'll be good at this point is there
anyone that they confirmed everyone if
they said that oh I don't think so this
new guy give them a go Chi ties the guy
I'm gonna pick one Chi [ __ ] I kind of
ton of moves yeah I did
arts your weapon is down back like gosh
there you go good good to go
yeah all right let's okay all right I
lost it can you pick it back up I pick
it up once I think once I lost it I you
you do the input again yeah you can't
get it back so air fists you've got a
power slide do two hand walking uh yeah
back left low kick yeah I'm down
I really am i serious whole thing you
seem to be based on moving fun yeah yeah
punching stuff apologize be bored
traffic just doing a PlayStation version
guess should be down back heavy cake oh
we're trying to figure this out
there it is now we're in business
oh no I can just knock you into the the
background you like we have to do the
input over again break my back that that
seemed pretty good oh I can steal your
weapon - I actually have an input oh
that's a good question
bring it back up here okay oh god that's
yikes up up up down and be a block a
block oh that's mine Eli's doing the
walking hands think it was block figured
it out up up three ups down and block
okay and that's outside
still have that real short we don't hold
the block you have two whole block a
stay on the ground that's a whole block
yeah that's my messed up yeah alright
we'll try it we'll try that hit that
button we don't need to see Quan Chi
what key drop again it's alright and we
got try all the characters but you get
all freaky now exactly do you want to do
the scorpion sub-zero one we'll do that
after I straighten still got why does
this look so bad ps2 version didn't like
that blocky did it
Vista ps1 yeah this is uh mk4 on the ps1
that is why oh yeah maximum damage I've
already mastered rep time teleport is
down up torpedo is ford forward light
kick it's gonna be quicker snap oh you
got your controller just compare future
if you try switching to analogs no there
you go there we go you got some sweet
teleports you got to do that torpedoes
is for a Ford light cake
get me a TiVo with mk4 I'm here for it
let's take reptile all the way Oh God oh
hello there oh you found your weapon an
elegant weapon for a rated citizen
pulling out a hammer I see I see that I
see that go on oh my god block press F
forward back up up high kick and high
kick would be triangle okay yeah
so hold block and then forward back up
up high kick okay forward back and you
can you can hold yeah I think we need to
be I think the any of you very very fast
he's very very fast am I not going fast
enough it's all good that's okay we'll
give it our best shot but uh no
guarantee we'll get any fits challenging
scoping Sub Zero yeah I'm always I'm
always doing scorpion sauce go that way
Oh so I'm saying pick up the weapon back
you have to be standing over the weapon
and press down and a or B on the 10th of
64 so that's hello there that's a thing
here let me check some zeros got to be
around here somewhere
there he is breezing wand you're
freezing wand down forward don't forward
heavy kick heavy kick okay
I think it's all on heavy kick for
weapons
oh no they're yokes that's not a wand at
all it's like a monster memo on I think
it's something else will you beat me up
I'm gonna check and see what my working
on my new jutsu there we go all right we
have that he can like gates Oh No
get over here
don't play the move later look I got too
into it you said except for the
fatalities I can't believe this no there
I go to my death
all right it is kind of fun to like kind
of fumble around and then be like oh
shoot says that's how you do that move
okay let's see I guess Jax do Jax
when elder Tanya Atanas in this life
yeah
whoo there's the forest we found it with
those Wiggly ovations check out my there
we go they didn't animate much into that
that's shot in animation oh it's there
we go Tonya's got some what's the hip
notch in the bottom that will hide your
cursor so that the other player won't
know what character you got a boomerang
nailed it Oh No
get him get him
101 America we're here makes like a
sound when you do this yeah got the
download downloaded me all right
okay neck break okay so you walk down
down up down a bunch down forward down
forward heavy kick okay I think that
might be an easier one all right all
right ready to dance a heavy kick is is
triangle like that's should be doing
yeah it's definitely trying to make sure
I'm not losing my mind I have a question
are you getting MK 11 yes very excited I
thought faster yeah this game moves very
quick we try this guy
Rico Graco I Franco no Rico phone
everyone yeah you're right I love
Nightwing I got a leap kit that I can do
across the I don't know I run off Fujin
and I remember I remember Rico because I
thought he is cool cause he had a base
business yeah see that's good
that was excuse me let's see what can I
do but there it is okay yeah that's good
I love just how silly something
animations look okay my my fatality
there you go four down four light punch
and block and I do oh oh
down down back light punch down down oh
no vets so that's the last two were for
different levels but so this is prison
fan there is a fan behind us
oh yeah I'm kind of wondering like
this'll be it I try it yeah I said go
for it so downtown backlight punch when
you're right
real close that light punch would be
it's it's it's a heavy thing hang bring
me back in Oh stage fatale you can throw
them into the vignette yeah prison fan
okay not touched on yet or kind just go
back to Johnny Cage to now the other
thing too is how long do you spend on
these games we have well I won't try at
least every character oh I don't think
anyone's quit Jared yeah I guess I'm
playing Johnny Cage nevermind he looks
not happy to be here
Johnny Cage yeah no oh poor Johnny king
Oh
morning so I think I would have this one
doesn't have the henna validates because
I know the whole thing with this one is
they were trying to be a little more
like they're trying to come back on the
cheese
yeah like free had some of that being a
I do like the way this game feels yeah
it's fast I don't know like I you barely
hear anyone talk about this people talk
about like Mortal Kombat games so I
don't know if just the the Mortal Kombat
communities kind of whatever about it
but god no trying to get back in there
what are you doing oh right I can't
believe this getting those those air
hits yeah yeah yeah yeah do it again do
it again
I just gotta sits there on it no man you
okay
alright decapitation is looks like it's
similar to what it used to be down down
for down block all right I'm down for
down block all right close oh did I do
it yeah I did it
ah those those old gushie water sound
effect yeah we got one
Oh old Johnny Cage I still fall to my
death coming in the clutch
oh you still have your head back so
that's alright
I think we've played everyone let's do
like at least two more okay then we'll
swap over I'm gonna try sub-zero so he's
pretty good she's got a lot of cool
kicks cool kicks we're playing on the
PlayStation
I didn't even pull out Johnny cages
sword Wow
she can't suck I played to a [ __ ]
caliber to be fooled by sidestepping
okay so we can't we can't on the floor
and I'll be a Benoit playas looking oh
good we can have Sub Zero and Sony on
the same page perfect that's
she's a vice - yeah oh I found my freeze
button thank goodness it's the same as
ever once or he does have slide bite
punch block what okay that's a real
weird employ oh excuse me yeah what kind
of four is actually really fun yeah I'm
with this one but that's kind of his
thing
man I feel good I hit maximum damage 1
it's like all oh man we gotta do this
okay
why rich the spine rip is the one
there's two inputs for it once this PC
off okay
so forward back forward down heavy punch
block and that's a lot heavy heavy punch
block now some people are saying the
stage fatality because this is oh this
is girls layer girl's layer so that
that's way easier yeah I do that one
dun dun dun light kick and I kick is
circle um
no light kick is yes I kick a circle
okay yeah cuz it's it's weird and
reverse of what I'm used to liking a
circle
alright do this do this yeah yeah there
we go thank you I pressed down three
times and light kicking definitely got
it we're getting some we're getting some
fatalities alright let's do one more one
more and more common for Scott a few
Johnny Cage
you want me to when we put two we go
hold on I think we can actually get real
close to both in case we need to pull up
a fatality I mean a little pause yeah
all right Oh back where it started the
original stage I need more crotch
punches what am i doing yeah yeah yeah
yeah jeez I'm on fire how do I do a
spear
it's four forward heavy keep thinking
it's forward it's it's like back forward
and Mortal Kombat 9 and that's the one
that keeps messing me up those face
punches
over here that's what I needed I'm here
too I could drop my size okay I got so I
did the the capitation so I'll try the
torso ribs forward back down down heavy
kick okay we're back down got it all
right ready yeah
no I wasn't ready
that's gay alright we're next one
slow up scorpion let's go there and fall
all the way down so what is the next
we're gonna do is it is it so special
forces you which one you came first
I think I feel like sub-zero might okay
first we could look it up and be totally
accurate but I feel like let's just get
sub-zero out of it yeah actually so I'm
gonna I'm gonna switch this over for so
don't want to have any weird like camera
stuff pop off there's so many chords
plugged into other chords here yeah yeah
okay what's what's cages maximum wage
we'll never know told you the curse
today is broken oh man
would you miss so we just got done
playing Mortal Kombat 4 on the
PlayStation we're moving on now to
mythology sub-zero which is a game that
I remember being very very difficult
these are is any of these other ones
co-op Shaolin monks I don't think so
okay if they are we can find out now but
I I the one thing I remember about
sub-zero was my friend brought it over
and he's like you try this Mortal Kombat
game it's like an adventure you should
get us whatever now yeah yeah and I
can't beat it so I want you to try it
and I started playing it and I got
further than him and I felt really good
about it but I didn't get very far
don't play the jacks that's what we got
to do solid car we got to touch on all
these games gray foxes they're not co-op
Matt bummer it's all right it's all good
we got we got Shaolin monks later on
mythology good luck with the jumping
yeah freakin Quentin Tarantino [ __ ]
it's really important that we know what
this is keeping those live-action things
and evil a war that would decide the
fate of the world and plunge it into
centuries of darkness now the war is in
danger of being fought once again only
one mortal can stop it
is it sub-zero no it's got a page
actually if only it were Johnny Cage me
the game would be better
whoo I got a different font okay like an
avatar okay
my options password and people preview
oh shoot
what's the preview is just that live
action video that played at the
beginning oh I hope so
dude we're getting all these cutscenes
yeah hey Lucas how's it going didn't
mind sub zero one monks one percent
better though it's pre enjoyable yeah
yeah that's what we're getting we're
looking forward to a little bit I mean
it's it's we're here for we're here to
touch on all right I'm ready for it
dude I'm so ready for yeah yeah doll
gimme welp see you later scorpion I
can't believe it so ride my moves
oh you can't wait oh you have to hit a
button to turn yeah yeah that's bad you
hear me out okay I'll just keep going
sure that guy's gone not great I'm Kate
live-action with the mc5 live-action
cutscenes it's a tough call so so this
is what I mean when the game is hard
it likes to throw things like that at
you what out of nowhere
yeah I'm gonna already say this game
it's not very good yeah crime seemed to
like it
I can see merits in it definitely sure
grew up with it it's not it's not for me
it's really it's really look I'd almost
anyone's like let's play Mortal Kombat I
would never assume that they meant
mythology sub-zero oh oh just kind of
yep that's their run by none I think
there is okay I gotta figure it out
you press here we go there yeah it's the
trigger
yeah okay perfect I got I got it got the
stage fatalities unlock this time around
that's right get over here get over here
that's the other guy she's got some
combos this guy
Northy brewmaster this game for current
gen systems i hope they wouldn't a man
disintegrated you have a literal pixel
of life yeah
no you can't do that you have to wait
for it to go first
I didn't even spell continue the game
but with a K bomber here you won't you
want me to try it this time
yep I'll give it so right trigger is
sprint and I believe left bomber is to
swap left bumper left trigger is to
rotate between the two angles okay all
right I'll use those blocks with ice or
maybe the early someone sang that so
none of these inputs are taken but yeah
it's not doing anything like that all
the moves you would think of I don't
really know how you you do some ice
watch we find out like it's it's a weird
like oh no oh no there we go yeah yeah
that's really awkward how you have to
you should just Auto like the fact that
you hope don't hold back and it doesn't
it's summer again okay there we go I
pick that up
Oh what you do to have to do that oh one
okay
yep I don't want it there they go cool
cool let me let me through
nice okay we're making progress
who are you we just jumped through this
doorway really quick nice oh okay so
it's giving you a symbol to do with
things I mean that I can I do it now
okay am i loud and I loud well who are
you yeah there you go
take that again okay so it's it's on
some kick okay that's the difference oh
they're really excited about weapon
technology yep cool let's do it
yep cool that wasn't it start again hold
on this is the best combo is just run
and you punch can i okay so I still have
that no I can't do it in midair alright
drop drop down nice how do you box nine
thanks for joining
hi playing a terrible video game when
the dole jeremy austin says i envy you
guys for playing this game i only got to
the second stage and then i quit playing
it's a very hard game i can't confirm
still as hard as i remember it
nice really upset that i jumped out of
that window and definitely died I mean
it seemed like the you know I don't know
it seemed like the right thing to do to
me alright I'm a ninja I should be able
to handle that yeah come here good he
just fell over okay so we don't jump
that way no whoa who else do I go up do
I go do I go back I don't want to fall
off again hello anyone well that way I'm
not oh and they come back oh they just
keep spawning
that didn't touch him did it no no there
we go
oh so go back to the balcony you see if
you can just like land on the balcony
I know these controls are very precise
we dress or guy to pop up again okay so
can you just like jump on the balcony
like on up there you know I mean likely
if you can land on that and then you can
jump up more oh my god jump now jump up
okay never mind there's no I thought
there really like a thing oh no no wait
that it's down there though there's a
thing down there yeah alright okay
alright that's fine
this is okay I bet I bet Special Forces
is gonna be better than this yeah nailed
it jump on the railing okay like like a
converses SNK - I'd love to
I'd really really love to and I didn't
run no queue on it you give it a go
again now no you're good I really don't
I super do not oh how about we run out
these these last three lives on this and
then okay and then we'll switch to okay
so sir
apparently you jump off the balcony but
stay close to the wall as there's
something to bounce uh-uh
so you got to jump it but you don't
fully full-on jump it yeah gotcha
I thought that was a someone called me I
thought it was too like a you know
whatever one of those like calls you
ignore but a debt collector yeah it was
the debt collectors I think it was the
UPS guy trying to get in to drop off a
package I was like oops Oh cram we would
love a tip absolutely yeah if you got if
you got you got tip send us that man
choose other character you can pick
another character oh man but this is
mythology sub-zero not mythologies
Baraka crabbed I grab that whatever it
is so he crime says jump at the ledge of
the balcony and then go straight down
and hold left okay
ledge the balcony straight down hold
left open up
there we go nailed that all right so you
got it jump up and then Oh see you then
I got a checkpoint I see it now very
nice so we've made it we're downstairs
well I gotta press my button to face the
person I want to fight I don't like that
that's a better than something in
testing and a bit like guys that's not
good no don't push me into there I swear
if you do there's no room oh I got wombo
combo by a bunch of pillars Wow
oh hey we checkpoint is we got that
checkpoint though all right so now I can
finally I've gotten enough experience to
be able to use the signature power of
Sub Zero and I can't turn around because
it got a hit a button well you have to
be standing straight and you have to hit
the button you just can't do it when
you're like crouching hold are you can
do on your crouching Julian says we
should play MK 9 yeah we're gonna get
there it'll do them all it'll happen
eventually he'll let me fight this guy
who's off-screen really fast ok all
right
there's to be a better way to do this
there I didn't run he's back the sort
guys back alright don't we try one more
try we're in it
perfect nailed it
best fight come and get me I know you're
in there
well can you get him yeah who are you
get him crush - okay all right
oh I can't believe this I think we're
done it's kissing you know I think we're
done with this one game over Yeah right
I'm down to swap over back again and I'm
going to put in we got a Shaolin monks
there's a shot known as a Shaolin monk
sorry best especially I think Special
Forces is gonna be more playable oh gosh
do we play them k4 already we already
did yes we played four and now we're
going through all of these spin-offs we
just did Sub Zero now we're gonna do the
pillars gonna be the reveal on today's
combat cast I'm here for it that'd be
pretty good human late sorry it's all
good I'm just glad that you're here more
combat four was really fun I really
enjoyed it
oh yeah I like that one a lot PS Special
Forces is the spin-off where you play as
Jack Jackson Briggs
alright that's that's all there for you
think we're good now come on over yeah
yeah there we go it's loading
I wonder playing MK deception I'll be
next time so I think next stream is
gonna be like the the main like 3d games
like deception and all of that so we'll
be playing some some cool Mortal Kombat
chess combat carding just general fights
oh man
excuse me is a spicy intro white so I'm
guessing all the silliness that they
didn't want to put into for just kind of
got siphoned off into this what excuse
me what is happening oh my god I love
the soundtrack so much it's a real shame
this games apparently terrible because
this is amazing
oops I'll get this guy in mortal combat
they're like you know what moral combat
needs like a James Bond video game Oh
what
oh my hell yeah I am I'm humped flew in
after that everyone's wrong this game is
awesome
mythology sub-zero nonsense I'm Way
ready for this just hit it yeah I'm
stoked
Duquesne oh he's wanted we gotta kill
for numerous crimes so what it's a yes
numerous crime than it listed them out
that's the name of the game roll the
credits we did it
there was no sound for that
they're like sound effects missing feel
like feel like yeah there should be more
could Njemanze MORTAL KOMBAT I know what
you mean yeah other incoming
transmission
is it Sonia oh no no no no Jarek Trevor
Schumer yeah
Sona in the chat was saying JK was
saying that this is the first appearance
for Trevor apparently you only fit so
much it has to be Kano tell him what
he's won this is so good from it
there's some weird I can't believe you
really think this game is cool I mean I
thought the intro was cool the intro was
sweet I've actually never played the
game so I imagine it's not very cool
because people say it's terrible I just
thought the intro was rad so this one I
think I've rented when I was at a
friend's house and I don't think we
actually played it this watches Marvel's
agents of combat oh heck yeah sign me up
I wants a combat cast I believe it's at
1 Pacific so in like an hour from now
you tell them Jax hey
okay I switch to oh you got young
there's like button accomplishing some
experience recover entertained fugitives
hiding in abandoned warehouse cool do I
got some combos no known combos no items
let's go beat some people up okay punch
kick other cake for the punch
just like Mortal Kombat block yep same
moves whoa whoa you can you can't
actually play now it's just for seeing
so beat him up beat him up beat him up
beat him up he's got so much life yeah
also what person would stroll up on a
guy with like metal arms and be like I'm
definitely beating this guy up this is
terrible now you're doing it you're in
it yeah
fatality convert their bodies in the
experience oh heck yeah PlayStation demo
discs and buying them in magazines I do
got a lot of PlayStation underground
demo discs hey Bob Jones Mortal snake 11
Oh
so apparently can do a run thing power
strike
I don't know if that's the thing we have
to learn first though you're playing as
Jax but what game is this this is Mortal
Kombat Special Forces it's not very good
young we'll be honest
watching it doesn't see me use the heat
action box Knight knows how do you do
that how where's the heat action can't
tell me how to do things I'm all for
doing stuff you won't like it like a
move list sure I don't know if it's like
your thing we're like a control scheme
how walkthrough how do you play more
combat Special Forces I find the page
and it just says you don't he's down
nope here we go there you go get some
sucker
level up it's a gain levels dear
abilities will become stronger and you
learn new combos so you can't even do
stuff until you unlock it okay yeah so
just xxxx track okay wow this game came
out in 2000 just came out after Metal
Gear Solid yikes oh dude
do you know what your turbo button is
now do you have like a sprint button or
like does any button make you run faster
like a trigger nope
try pressing any one of them in like a
punch button like I wanna punch r2 a
punch okay there you go so you've got
your special moves yeah that's the
trigger there's a light ground pound and
a hard ground pound and a light - punch
and a hard - punch brakes and ground
pounds are on punches how it actually
shows the combos oh yeah did that combo
heck yeah there you go later now we're
figuring it out like that looks more
like Colossus than Jax the only thing
missing is him just going to her every
time he spins around or hit someone okay
we're getting there we're getting there
were figuring out yeah we've got the
download on this game it's heavy
Heidi was a hind in this weather
Colonel Rousey of urban chaos
yeah there's a lot of I feel like
there's a lot of inspirations being
drawn here oh did you just blow that man
up with your fists that's pretty good
you're also running low on punch juice
oh no not my punch juice Oh what else to
call it
oh I miss fighting force we excuse me
you're definitely out of punch was a
good majora's mask 20 out for a skater
to deus ex perfect dark double sun god
geez yeah door locked but you can't
punch through it
or can you
think I exploded yeah and that key never
mind
okay old Elle wine to look oh he'll
choose to take out and put the weapon
away okay that's definitely what I think
of when I think of us some machine goes
that's how you shoot okay
can you can you shoot in third-person
like just running around like this you
like pull it out there you go yeah you
can now we're cooking no elevator power
you have to sweat two keyboards you know
I have no ammo though that's good you
give me a machine gun but no ammo I
think there's a boss coming up
it's the Punisher get a purple health
bar so I thought he was gonna be harder
guess not that hundred fists rush we got
to get some cannon here yep got a clip
there we go the DARPA chief was nowhere
to be found
do you were going to shoot some people
now all 25 of those shots
Hey okay okay okay so now I go back up
you can get into the power room to put
power to the elevators and take the
elevators this is figured it out
Syphon Filter may have inspired this
game his run isn't whacky enough to be a
syphon filter run and that's the biggest
injustice here
injustice gods among us yeah that's the
one oh man alright so now we go back
here
Elvis I will say I think this is better
than a subzero one oh definitely
Check Point I'm surprised no one likes
spawned out here for you to fight after
you yeah I was really expecting that
like that was one of those weird like
gamer instinct like I felt it in my
bones I felt like there's gonna be like
three dudes you popped out wow this is
low okay
so I'm seeing the Metal Gear Solid a lot
more now to come here hello oh my god I
just like in actual three cool murders
heck yeah
all right I'll try it first personnel
though I only have four bullets that's
fine
that's alright I like heat wanna like
like you know shimmy up against there
against the wall Oh ammo come on give me
some all right that works from scheme on
ps1 yeah I remember it being a big I
don't I remember playing it all right
like I said I think I think me and my
friend rented it with another game and
we just never played this which I'm sure
made his parents very happy so we kept
insisting no it's really cool it's it's
Mortal Kombat but it's an adventure game
as this game can endure the timeline I
think any game could probably be
considered canon just because of how
much like time manipulation and
alternate dimension manipulation happens
in Mortal Kombat all right play some for
a couple minutes and we're gonna get to
the real the real winner and boom
backwards Hideo Kojima wait okay nope
hold on guys
just gotta kind all these guys I see
what you're doing this is cool
yeah oh yeah I got a third guy where'd
he come from he looks like he was just
maybe an innocent bystander okay there
doesn't seem to be much of a reason to
go to first person at least not right
now
yeah it's kind of more of a pain we all
had that one friend regretted buying
this game I Finn how you doing welcome
I feel like he's be able to bust that
door down or that wall down maybe get
like a rocket launcher and that's how
you do it no that window looks like it's
right for jumping through oh it's not
way to jump though it's true there's no
way to jump oh hey there oh yeah people
go down in real quick frame rate yeah
access denied no get that security
access sorted out so we'll go back to no
loading while using the elevator
Metal Gear Solid whoo
yeah I'm also kind of getting like
really strong Metal Gear flashbacks and
that's that's maybe the nicest thing you
can say about this game yeah that seems
fair that you generally get that much
damage done to you with a gun but then
you just tap them guns do like realistic
damage yeah that's a weird thing in a
game where's tremor we gotta find him
first
Bert you look super uppercut no should
try that
heck yeah and a large med pack for me oh
you think I come in with a sweet he's
been playing on that there it is and
I'll just shoot him nailed it
that's man hey can you all do Street
fire the movie arcade video game with
jean-claude Van Damme yes because we
actually have a copy I bought a copy in
Japan because that's the kind of person
I am no this is a strong lean up into
just doing like any sort of dumb
fighting video game Evo thing that we
want to do oh man I'm having a decent
time with this well I am I'm having kind
of a dumb fun like it's definitely not
good but it's not for us so it's it's it
hasn't gotten to the point where you
wanted to throw the container which is
good I'll find an explosive
oh yeah forums so it sounds like it's
hello it sounds like it's a c4 from
metal gear yeah yeah perfect another
elevator all those I think this is just
the way around oh okay
so they can go back to the other floor
and use that on those other hey exactly
we're figuring it out wasn't our Street
Fighter game like this with gaming guile
I think it was a cannon spike was a game
with Cammy in it
if I'm not mistaken is there a 100 hit
combo that can be done I hope so big Z
I'm trying to figure out if Jax has just
a backpack on it's a great key card all
right where was that set up on the top
floor I think was on the third no was on
the fourth floor on the fourth floor
okay it was like down in to the right
was the third or fourth well around a
third so second there was underneath
where you were before to try it try a
second it's true there are no pillars in
this game yet it goes down in to the
right that way that's definitely not her
maybe it isn't it yeah maybe it's not it
Wow uh who is he get that combo on
lockdown and I got a gun now so we're
all good yeah don't escape is close it's
a different thing
are there any fatalities we did blow
some people up by punching them which
was a lot of fun
Chris swore was on this floor maybe we
lost it now it might have been the third
floor yeah but you know it was like down
to the right
I can blow that up at least yep there's
that yeah
intruder game is way too dark I think
that's the stylistic choice I'll take it
fire alarm what did you pull the fire
alarm
yeah so now the firearm are the fire
doors oh yeah hey now more magic show
I'll see that what that was where it
happened hidden want to do it too early
yeah can't spike on dreamcast Cammy a
bunch of other Capcom characters
including Megaman shoot King spike might
have been the other one then I run it on
the fire escape though we'll probably
call it and switch to the next one
Shaolin monks Shaolin monks happy Friday
back at you snack it's good to see ya
I'm glad you're here Jax is the original
one punch man all right I'm down well
when I when I think of Jax though like
the the move that I think of is always
the gotcha grab say I love it cuz just
he says gotcha every time he does it oh
hello there sound a little bit of
loaning
da-da-da-da-da-da house minding his own
business
who's this muscly boy there we go dang
perfect are we doing two-player Shaolin
monks we are don't know who's gonna play
is who perfect open posture all right
let's do it oh shoot yeah we got da we
go to a boss fight yeah look at those
combo breakers ooh
is that part of the song no face he has
a hot temper fast knowledge and the use
of explosives beware of airborne
dynamite those who play with fire will
get burned again
dang that's pretty good dude this music
music is fantastic
oh my god I'll tell you you gotta use a
health pack there's no shame in that
oh oh he's got combos - oh yeah that's
true great Fox wants to remind you when
you're done make sure you save sue don't
you send me the game on hand yeah yeah
this music is lit oh it's joke because
the guy is doing the players
the problem is I'm trying to find an
opportunity to get him after the
business there's not a lot of wise
that sound effect I know that sound of
thing it's like no wiggle room to a hit
up that's kind of like there's no room
for me to get in there when he's
shooting his plane launcher the sound
effect is the same sound that doom guy
makes when he's in like when when he
when he gets hurt I can't unhear it
who's in a studio gotcha oh it out read
it out
that wasn't a boss fight that was a
murderer that was not very good and know
that you were a Special Forces Master
you should have just told me
damn there's what literally one hint
room well please give us another weird
nauseous the transmission and shoot use
the Stinger missile launcher we get to
do like a fatality on the black dragons
wanted for terrorism smuggling extortion
murder dang death yeah pretty much
oh yeah there you go make sure you save
your game yeah all right let's show an
monks time oh heck cat is uh I'm ready I
did I'm gonna switch this over so yeah
look cuz I gotta switch systems now
camera all right this is this is the big
switch the one that we're pushing off
until until as late as we could but I'm
very excited so who who who are you
gonna play I do want to be which which
character okay all right I'm into it
these controllers out of the way they're
trying to clean it up a bit here whose
voice acting Jack's that's a good
question I can actually look that up
right now while we're doing that let's
look up some Mortal Kombat Special
Forces I am DB [ __ ]
I'm gonna be really surprised if there's
a an IMDB for this all there is oh you
can swap over to the game now I think
yeah here I'll wait I'll wait see get
the game in I need a pop Jax was voiced
by I'm sorry
there's a game in here already what what
are you doing I just grabbed a random I
grabbed an Xbox is this I didn't know
there is a game in here I really hope
it's what I think it is because
DreamWorks and Activision so it's a
movie game probably there's one this
DreamWorks DreamWorks does a lot of
things I don't know who the heck that is
seriously though parfait oh my god it's
trick to bed did you miss did you push
copies for two in the sex box I actually
had nothing to do with this is our brand
isn't maxime who did this who did this
to us
god damn it oh they're very sick so - I
struck two let's play series many would
clearly derail they're not doing Mortal
Kombat anymore the entire Shrek series
play live ah you know those jams
all right but seriously yes you are
god damn it yeah I don't know who did
that I don't know where I came from
anyway we're actually gonna play shall
we monks for real all right we're good
now
perfect you could bring bring oh yeah we
just xbox menu I was trying to just
trying to keep it clean you know I
appreciate that yeah yeah consistent um
yes I'll keep up whatever just wait for
it - there we go
I did this is the only controller I
played the original Xbox with oh it's
it's built for my big dumb hands it's
perfect I love it Shrek and all the
stress spin-offs revisiting the shrink
series okay we actually got shrekd live
that was real weird this game is
actually kind of dark yeah so check the
options if there's a brightness maybe we
can turn it up in the game ah ha ha
perfect didn't make us we can see that
m'kay logo yeah much better
oh yeah way always turned all the way
down way better
that's really weird okay go up right
yeah go up with the K alright so so do
you want to be Liu Kang or Kung Lao
I do like Kung Lao a bit alright you've
been you've been really good at bicycle
kicks lately with Luke
so by normal I got nothing proving
Shaolin monks there's a code for
unlocking characters we could have done
no the other care give me a long trek
they did the yell yeah he yelled Mortal
Kombat
oh there's Johnny Cage wait a minute
that's how the more wilcott they'll all
fight at the same time mess them up
Johnny Cage the one they watch the other
one spice oh yeah playing it fast and
loose
kino it's my turn oh this Johnny doesn't
happen
ah that's pretty good let's go say he
doesn't have this a tattoo on his chest
yeah I'm not yes oh my god no leave my
boy alone
excuse me so I think we're gonna hope
this liked this tutorial yeah there it
is again this is not how the attorney
this is not a tournament it's just a
brawl yeah it's just a fight it's a real
Royal Rumble dang he's quick
oh it's me Oh it seizes me okay yeah
yeah that's fair
mess him up
this whole scene which is kind of like
hey you guys like Mortal Kombat check
out Mortal Kombat remember when subscrip
that guy's spine out I do I do remember
that we did it again Oh
jim-jim Liu Kang Sukho for the through
the whole roster giving him some real
solid punches uh-oh who's he reaching
for who's in happen who's in the doorway
it's goro majima majjhima everywhere
it's a really long intro yeah right
they've got to show you all the
characters
yikes so I never understood why Goro has
like green on his back but I've always
questioned
doing some firebending open another
portal seal feeder that's all what
happens
we must return to Lucy Academy
we headed back to the Lucian Academy
I don't know but then liu kang and kung
lao fell in the hell i can't believe it
i wish to fight our way out never forget
how Goro throws Johnny Cage yeah it's a
good throw all right Goro here this is
just like the like a hit stay out of war
clone it's kind of like I I remember
being more like a like a Streets of Rage
kind of okay yeah this is pretty good
quality for for when this came out like
I'll say he just leaves about them I
grabbed the tutorial thing oh we got
some people coming out of the shadows to
beat him up all right I got this one you
take that one I can't because the camera
doesn't let me move
okay yeah yeah yeah you got some juggles
happening all right yeah this is pretty
cool actually I'm doing this
now's a good time I have a charge thing
going on oh my teleport from a grab
button
yeah yeah yeah yeah
air combos grab them throwing
there's a lot of sound effect yeah yeah
all right so I'm remembering how to do
all the special things - okay throw my
hat jugglin happening nice get him get
him on the ground I'll cut his head off
good job pick up this mushroom nice nice
let's go
Thanks right if you like people might
have accidentally done yeah there we go
hit him with the rock throw him up in
the air throw I had at him oh just kick
that man into a ring I do like how
Mortal Kombat games always seem to have
like a lot to unlock and they have
things to figure out oh yeah we're gonna
get into that with the when we get to
the next one they always had like the
weird modes they added in the like
PlayStation Xbox ones
knock them down yeah this is a good time
I'm having fun
I'd be down for like a rebooted this so
like another we didn't well combat like
spin off beat them up do much perform
okay hit me feel like you knew you've
got it you find your bicycle kick button
yeah no not yet so it might be you so
the you do special attacks by pulling
down multi-directional cops
Oh God holding down right trigger and
then any of your face buttons do it okay
oh there's my
oh that's a one's just an uppercut
yeah yeah yeah wash them up into the air
get that stylish meter going oh that's
exactly if the devil trigger starts
playing I wish my hat would ricochet
still get to the bicycle kick I just
have a mom you still teaming up in
Morecambe at 11:00 I'm really excited
about that too
the juggle on through welcome to the
fire what happening yeah oh yeah got'em
yeah some thing we have to buy moves Oh
weapon combat here we go here we go who
got dismemberment happening nice yeah
sure you had those crazy things when you
get the the points unlock the stuff for
it we should just come back to this and
do a whole playthrough this I'm really
into it it's kind of into it too yeah
time oh man
another classic location spelled with a
k knock them up into it yeah doo doo doo
cha oh my boy did the thing it's okay
guys I still have the EZ fatality unlock
just up or cut them off coop it's so
it's like co-op hits cuz we're here both
hitting him but this note it's just coop
it it's just coop its coop its
do-do-do-do something oh is that a
reference I think it's a reference oh
goodness
jump off of my large hat to get to the
next platforming section
I can't wait to knock people off of this
so I'm gonna show up so Sid is
recommending that you try doing forward
triangle than jump and Prasad pressed
four times so for triangle I have to
drop these weapons so for triangle then
we'll jump and then press so nice I just
jumped down with them I do like how it's
cutting away to show it to us every time
okay so I can do a roll when I do four
time
that's pretty cool I know that's what he
wanted but I'm just doing some Kuwait
photos yeah did you say my final cost on
the moon there I did yeah is this ninja
gaiden I mean what if ryu hayabusa
showed up Yan Cheng all did the monkey
roll
want to see if I can mess with them I
can't oh here we go
it should have yelled Mortal Kombat when
that happened the music is playing
oh yes that's cool
Filip and combos jumped on me
you got your feet down I did it
Oh do it I did it yeah
cut him in half I see we've fed blood
into the door and satisfied the door
gods once the combat caste should be in
about 30 minutes oh man
we need more beat-em-ups
yeah like we're we're all the
beat-em-ups go
so they got like the the takeover is one
that's out now there's another one that
was pretty good
I want more though we're getting
straight to rage for two yes maybe there
are more beat'em ups and i just not
thinking about them
I gotta do it but uh-oh maybe it's cuz
ie I did like the tutorial one oh do I
need to like look them up you have to
discover them all Oh weird huh
so they still kept it a secret we've
actually many members but in here I'm
glad you here to like this is try no we
got some hot tips for a fatality for ya
if anyone's got some good fatalities for
me
yeah this is hell
I mean things why we wanted to do like
the like trying out the older games cuz
it's been a while and there are also
games that like so you want to miss out
on it existed it's really cool just kind
of look at them photography Liu Kang is
down left up right square so then BX
yeah yeah all right
that's one good the bicycle kick oh
thank you
it's a good call do so in salute king
yeah
anyone for Kung Lao you give me the best
Kung Lao fatality you can remember
watch me botch it live about we got
throw them in the throw them into over
here oh it's that wall definitely that
prevail
Liu Kang left up up right X salute Liu
Kang's you I'm Luke a right [ __ ] nice of
handyman
okay here we go come Lao up right down
left triangle up right time okay well
get in the next one
Scott right up up X right right up up X
looks like a save point yeah yeah save
this for later up down up right square
okay we got we got fatalities on deck Oh
No I can't believe they broke the bridge
up just went right for it
a mini-boss hello you're supposed to
fall right someone do dude it down well
this is one we did before I think no
it's not he's gonna grab his legs and
pull them through perfect that's good
whoo hello check that guy into those
things threw him over there all right
I'm with you now I'm not the way now
okay you can't block his big hit
see in case you want to know oh but you
can't dodging it it has like iframes
left up up right eggs you you got it
oh man it just seems a little overkill
yeah it's a little bit
go on up right down and left triangle it
didn't work we'll get it
Oh apparently it's a up right down left
triangle is a murat merged morality Oh
which is weird because what hey you know
we'll get there eventually
and try it again all right it's up right
down left triangle does that might be
for nothing for you oh whoa I'm flying
now you're Oh Griffin yeah rice and
realize where I was oh god I died we
both died oh we're too busy doing
fatalities that we weren't behind listen
to reading carefully we do look I was
tries to busy trying to do cool killing
moves look you apparently got to get to
bars to do that alright let's let's do
this for real
let's get that the real run back on this
he doesn't say do you want after we beat
this guy do we want to call here yeah
it's probably good good idea all right
let's get this boy and get ready for
that
combat cast we're all excited for it or
gonna get to see you cybot smooth
breakdown and enterin black and someone
new
really how to jump every time she just
hits the ground too hard
there we go it's really good shirt
helpful yeah
he's known for again oh no
spinning around
XP boost I couldn't get away fast now we
got him yeah don't die
he's number one tip stones i/o we picked
up a thing learned a thing tap into the
Mortal Kombat become the Mortal Kombat
along John
well short jump and long jump okay so we
can use it to get back on the break I
like it
yeah you want to hit the save point and
then we can yes up nope
I made it Oh Jake's okay I'll let you go
first they are we've done it we've made
it okay stop heck yeah
all right that's a very good time this
is a successful stream I was yeah I I
think these games uh are a lot better
than I remember them except for
mythology subs no that was terrible
don't don't recommend that one Special
Forces at least that first level was
like not terrible
yeah okay I still like the one part
where you one-shot the bus that was yeah
good yeah that boss seemed badly
designed yeah I like this one a whole
Shaolin monks a plus more combat for
better than I remember it
that's really cool yeah and I hope you
guys had a good time next time yeah we
will play the 3d trio the 3d trio on the
Xbox
Deadly Alliance and deception and
Armageddon yeah bye all three of those
just be really fun time you guys ready
you struck two is here for some reason
or two hour struck two let's play series
yes we're gonna play Shrek 2 it'll be
great I hope your stay there please
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss a single shrek let's play or
anything else we do take easy guys
see ya see you later see ya goodbye
button I've done it